how's it going bros my name is peter
pack it's time
for another q a it's been a while
so it's time got a lot of great
questions
let's just get into it is there a single
thing about your career you'd change
what would that be and is your choice
because of public opinion or personal
first question i don't know
i'd like to make more serious videos
i've been doing a lot of just
reacting stuff lately but even though
people say they like them they don't
generally do well so if it was all i did
it wouldn't really work but we'll see
when's the next music video dropping
it's colby we're trying to do something
different it's going to take a lot
longer but we're working on it
what is a feature you feel like you two
could implement that would be beneficial
for people making content on this site
youtube is pretty good now just make
everything work that's all they got to
do
what are your plans for holidays and
vlogs after cobin floor gang out
hell yeah uh i'm going to japan straight
away and see my parents of course of
course mom i'm coming
don't worry when you retired where will
your ideal retirement country plays
view what you're living i don't know
this is the problem of being extremely
rich
you could live anywhere how can you
choose
i don't know we're gonna try japan since
you started a healthier lifestyle
did you notice improvements in your
thinking or just your body
ever since no nut my gaming skill
improved
my nails stronger i can claw stuff
no telekinetic powers yet but i know
they will come
i am i just gotta wait are you enjoying
youtube more since you decided to take
respects instead of everyday uploads
i noticed you really enjoyed the member
community too it's nice to see i don't
know if i
particularly like youtube more but i
like my life more
i enjoyed uploading every single day and
working every single day because i was
enjoying youtube so much but i realized
this is not a
healthy way to live you know actually
just playing games on my own and stuff
like that
how often do you get writer's block how
do you counter it i got a great tip
as soon as you get it just start looking
for inspiration look at people that you
inspire you and see what they're doing
and just get ideas and maybe you'll get
some inspiration
don't waste time trying to force
something it's a good time to just
recognize
all right i'm kind of stuck move on to
something else dave taught me that it's
great
what's the absolute best memory you have
for your career that's a tough one
i don't know i had so many great moments
oh my god
so many trips you know singapore even
sweden
i don't know i don't it's just been so
many the whole journey
yeah yeah that's my answer yeah
are you going to talk about letters of a
stoic saw the book on the desk
in one of your live streams well spotted
probably not
i love it it's a great book check it out
i'll probably make some video on the
stolix
if i do a video next but i'm not sure if
exactly
sanaka is the one i'll pick when you
meet a person and they want to develop a
friendship with you how do you go about
it
like how do you know they're not just
for the fame
you get a sense for it in in very in
very subtle ways you can tell what
people do
uh when they interact with you so it's a
weird skill that you learn to develop
what do you what do you think about
being commonly associated with normies
and annoying reddit kids as seen in the
recent starter pack video or does that
not concern you
at all i mean i'm so used to that being
so
uh cringe popular it it's always been
the case
i don't care it's fun i want to be
underground and no one else finds out
about pewdiepie
then he's much cooler how do you feel
about the idea of aging and death wow
we're really taking
big leaps here and when do you see
yourself no longer uploading i guess
when i'm dead
for sure uh so stoicism again
really helped me at least uh come in
terms with the idea of aging and death i
mean a lot of philosophy is just based
around
everyone's gonna grow old everyone's
gonna die how do you deal with that
that's literally the
start of buddhism now if anything i just
see it as a virtue i
it's completely changed my mindset it
used to be something that i
when i was younger i would struggle to
fall asleep just from the anxiety of
thinking about death and
the universe and quantum physics oh yeah
i'm really happy
i i've been able to change my mindset
around it especially how
it puts you in the moment more as well
which i enjoy uh i know you've been a
we go from existentialism to anime i
know you've been watch
a bunch of anime which one would you
recommend check out my anime list
myanimelist.net
user slash beauty films i think or is it
pewdiepie
you can judge all my anime ratings there
do you ever worry that youtube is
impacting too much of your mental health
especially with the media scrutinizing
everything you do
if so how do you deal with it hey
all right can we recognize i've been a
good boy lately
huh no controversies huh where's my
you know a badge a little star
little check mark check no controversy
for a while
check no all right
fair i i just think i i realize that i
enjoy making videos i don't enjoy making
all this spectacle all the time it
doesn't necessarily affect me
that much but it's a thing where if it
keeps going for a long time it just gets
kind of exhausting i would say
uh would you like to keep working on
youtube after you retire maybe
what they need is someone who truly
understands creators
oh working on like as an employee
no bruh
i never have to work again i don't have
to be here you understand
i've already retired i decided a couple
months ago
i'm doing youtube any more low pace i'm
sorry
that means i am not uploading as
frequent as i am but i just decided
i'm retired yeah have you noticed any
difference
how are you doing these days great thank
you also would you do another book
review i love your philosophy and book
beat okay
okay okay okay i will i will
as soon as i have time i'm busy on a lot
of stuff right now i'll do it do you
have any long terms or gold yeah
speaking of which
music i know the times are weird right
now but maybe you have plans
music music is coming prepare
yourself do you ever still feel like
they're leaving your channel
and starting a new one so you don't have
to handle the pressure being the biggest
challenge yes
absolutely i i couldn't do it though i
have
too many contracts i i was thinking
about it
a few days ago actually i was like well
the only thing i don't like about
youtube the only thing that bothers me
is just how much
people put that my influence
right oh he has his audience he has to
be a certain way
it's other people imposing on me how i
should act
which is really annoying i just enjoy
making videos without caring what
a group of people that don't watch me
think but i can't really do that
in the position i am so have i grown
more responsible
no no i have not i'm just more cautious
also do you sometimes feel like you
aren't breaking more molds or
and being creative with your youtube
content own owing to you being the one
the largest creators on the platform
um i think if you watch one of my videos
to figure out who i am and you find out
this is the biggest creator on youtube
look at him
he's just doing a [ __ ] q a yeah it
looks dumb
but we got a whole library all right and
it's epic
so no i think i like my study videos
thank you very much
i've been working out for a few weeks
now good for you eric observing the
routine you posted on instagram stories
before
nice what advice can you give to keep
someone's motivation
working out cheers have a great day
compliment
your workout with literature lit
fit good food it's the ascension
once you decided to join you'll be
motivated for the rest of your life
i know you said someone meets you
randomly on the street and asks for a
pick
you will decide decline yeah that's
right and that's
completely understandable but if i ever
by some ungodly amount of luck to meet
you on the street could i hug
you no it's covered what are you doing
if it wasn't covered yes otherwise not
no hit go near me
what's the next gameplay you're gonna do
i miss those times
when i'm waiting for your live broadcast
i still hate how joel died
rogano uh all right i decided
big announcement
gaming december gaming
month is happening prepare yourself what
started your path towards living life
how does it affect your life since you
started
i just always hated having stuff and
then i decided hey i hate it so much
let's just get rid of all this [ __ ] look
how little stuff there is in my room it
feels
i don't know it's just a personal thing
i i hate having stuff
and as a youtuber i get sent stuff
constantly
rich people problem coming right up you
see the oculus in the back i have one i
love it it's great
now i have two i i mean three what am i
going to do with these
i don't nee why
ah rich people problem i don't i
it happens all the time this is the
problem with rich people we get
everything for free
it makes no sense it's like when uh you
get recognized in a shop they're like
you can have it for free i'm like
no no no this is all wrong this is all
wrong
looking back to the past and now what's
something that you're gonna regret
at first but now you're glad of it oh
that's deep um i have no regrets
on my youtube what are you talking about
how do you maintain balance in life yeah
life advice how do you do things that
you enjoy but take responsibility at the
same time
set goals for yourself every day i'm
gonna do this
this and this and then i can do whatever
the [ __ ] i want
yeah make bullet points it feels good
i did it i did it
basically work first play later yeah
when you decided to quit drinking liquor
how did you do it
did you have people in your life that
helped you push
you towards that decision and then help
you follow through with it
do you have anyone that tried to
convince you to continue to drink
like there was an in issue now no one in
my
it came from me basically i just decided
but anyone that tried to convince me to
continue drink
yeah it's called society
it's one of those weird things where
it's like everyone does it so it's
normal right but it's
why should you cut it down if everyone
else does it and it surrounds you
everywhere too so it's kind of hard to
realize no just because other people do
it
doesn't mean i have to do it that's
actually a thing i learned recently it's
because everyone does it doesn't mean
it's right
what are you reading watching playing
right now i have not finished sarah
zustra i'm like 50 pages left
i just started watching blood of zeus
and i'm playing hades hey
that's kind of on theme there
yeah what's your philosophical
standpoint in life
that sensational pleasures will never
give you long-term
happiness okay long-term happiness comes
from flourishing in life and being the
person that you want to be
the best version of yourself excuse me
while i drink this g
fuel when you're done with youtube
you're going to pass a pewdiepie
challenge to someone else
that makes no sense scythe here you go
take over the channel
so guys i've got a subreddit of mine
i'm joking scythe i'm not going to give
it to you sorry
i'm joking again a double joke
oh this is interesting why do you feel
uncomfortable or annoyed sometimes when
other people are screaming or speak loud
mostly on among us but you often scream
in your own video
great question it's almost like it's
different how you act when you're on
your own
or in interacting with other people yeah
i don't yell in front of other people
that's rude i don't do that [ __ ]
unless i really know them well after all
these years on youtube what are things
that keep you uploading video
money money money money and what are
things that sometimes makes me want to
quit
i hope not i'm joking uh i really enjoy
the interacting with my fans
i know that sounds cliche and yes it
probably is but
it's true i love i still read comments i
love making videos i love filming videos
side let's get real there's scythe
there's all the hard work
thank you side
i just get to do all the fun stuff and i
hope maybe i've enjoyed some of it
uh what books would you recommend
someone starting out to learn philosophy
um start with the greeks i actually
i noticed i made this mistake when i
started reading the stoics everyone
always talks about marcus aurelius but
it's not a great book
to start off with i would probably start
with the sanaka or epicurus or something
like that
it'd give you a much better base maybe
epictetus actually
start with him if you want to get into
stoicism
you sometimes feel overwhelmed by all
the people who either support
look up to you look down on you talk
crap or dislike you
hey i feel really weird about the fact
that people like my videos
i still don't get it it still hasn't
sunk in
or that people are genuine fans it's
like wait
what there's all these other people here
yeah you're like
you have some more markiplier hey mr
beast is over here
over here what are you doing here hi
let's get really
as a kid have you experienced any
embarrassing moments in public
no chad all my life thank you i have no
stories of my childhood that are
embarrassing to tell sorry guys
book recommendations for minimalist but
wholesome limit
you don't need a book for that all right
just throw away all your [ __ ]
what are something your wife has
introduced you that you really enjoyed
animal crossing
[Laughter]
when are you bringing back minecraft to
the channel gaming month
gaming tips on being an extrovert
if i know i no
you trust me you don't want to be an
extrovert all right they get all the
attention
they get all the [ __ ] they get every
you don't want you don't want to be in
nah
what do i think about the playstation 5
finally someone asked now i can answer
this
it's ugly it's really ugly if anything i
look forward to the new uh
controller the next gen controllers
because the micro usbs are so annoying
like
unbelievably outdated the console itself
doesn't matter it's about the games on
the console and so far there's not that
many
games so really if you're buying the
playstation 5 right away it just seems
like you care more about
showing off that you have products
instead of
the product itself you're shallow
but yeah i'm gonna get one day day one
i wish it would it's ugly right it's
ugly come on
and it's so big maybe it looks better in
person i look forward to see it
i just feel like pla sony always had to
design down
that's their thing would you ever try
the long and big
long hair big beard combo go full biking
hell yeah braid my hair oh you're gonna
take another break in january hell yeah
oh
january no games no revenue
do you think you'll ever beat sean in
bottle flight competition
next year is going to be mine sean
you're done
don joe i've been practicing every day
do you ever miss the times when you
weren't famous yes i hate being famous i
really
do if you wouldn't you wouldn't be
famous then why did you do youtube
channel
i didn't know i just wanted to play
games online man
what that means to gun them i don't know
i don't remember i think i just bought
it by mistake in japan one
i'm doing a this one custom painting
every little piece
every little goddamn piece
i just have to build it okay
i just haven't been bothered have you
decided on charity for this month
yes movember we're donating didn't i not
say this
as that's the reason i have the mustache
favorite book at the moment all right
this is the last question i'll show you
i said about me for my birthday and i'm
so happy i finally own
a real art a copy of the iliad of homer
1856. it's beautiful
it's just because i i read it when i was
really young
just like a dumbed down version and i
loved it then
and then to re-read it as an adult just
was such a fun experience
it's a perfect example of why i love
literature you can go
back in time and relive those moments or
people
idolized or imagined for the that time
it's incredible love it thank you for
watching a q a
hope you enjoyed look at the graph yeah
you know what to do thanks for watching
guys brofist
we've hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most relevant of games
we look far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and
interesting topics but then there is one
subject
that we somehow missed welcome home my
tuber friends
every home is different and love is
central to every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings